how can we stop messing with the climate
to start answering this question it's
useful to break the carbon climate
problem into four components admissions
concentrations climate change and
climate impacts first the emission of
carbon dioxide and other long-lived
greenhouse gases that can alter the
climate emissions are the human cost
flow of greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere they're typically measured in
tons of carbon dioxide equivalent per
year total global emissions are about 40
billion tons per year the weight of 40
cubic kilometers of water in personal
terms that's about five and a half
tonnes per year per person on average so
we are not all equal contributors given
how much I fly I'm responsible for about
30 tons per year whereas a typical
member of the poorest billion humans is
responsible for only a tenth of a tonne
per year here is how global emissions
have been growing over the last century
what you see is accelerating growth with
a few pauses during times with a global
economy faltered tourism is no evidence
of a slowdown over the decades since
1992 when the world first made formal
commitments to work together to cut
emissions to protect our climate second
the concentrations of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere this is the amount of
carbon dioxide gas in the atmosphere at
any one time we care about this because
it's the amount of greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere that is what most
directly causes climate change in any
given time here is how global
concentrations have been growing over
the last century you see very steady
growth with a slow even acceleration